we want to make sure everyone's seen and
heard which is why we've got to shut up
the public
we are trying to make sure that everyone
is seen and heard this wouldn't even be
such a big deal if it wasn't for board
members trying to push this and get the
public involved
perfect example of what's going on in
our broader public discourse
right now there's a school in oregon
that is demanding
that in its classrooms they fly
not just an american flag they probably
wish they could take that down but they
can't
but then next to the american flag at
the very same size
as the flag the gay pride flag
and the black lives matter flag
apparently black lives matter has a flag
so this is progressive pride right i
mean this is these are progressive flags
why would the schools do this i mean you
you have
an american flag in your classroom
because it's your country and you have a
loyalty to your country
and the classroom could not exist
without the country that's you pledge
allegiance because it's your country
but do i now have to pledge allegiance
to blm an actual
marxist organization if i go to the
school in oregon
i have to pledge allegiance to the pride
flag
what if what if i'm christian or a
jewish or muslim what if i
what if i don't go along with the pride
ideology what if i don't think that boys
can become girls and girls can become
boys
just by wishing it so then i am not
i'm not welcome in that classroom right
that is not the kind of education i'm
getting
there was a leaked clip there was this
one woman the i guess the
somewhat conservative woman on the
school board saying guys this is a
little crazy we gotta we should cut this
out probably
and the progressive on the school board
one of the progressives on the school
board says
absolutely not shuts down the debate it
is a total
analogy is there a perfect example of
what's going on in our broader
public discourse well i mean you know
i've also been receiving a lot of racist
hate mail
as well because of this policy i think
it's very important that we
make a stance and we confront that all
this pushback is wrong
and honestly the amount of pushback that
i'm getting back from the board it's not
cool either
like what robin said this is stalling
it's pushing white supremacy
it's getting in the way of progress like
you tell me when in human history
progress was a bad thing
we are trying to make sure that everyone
is seen and heard
this but this policy wouldn't even be
such a big deal if it wasn't for board
members trying to push this and get the
public involved
this is just pushing unnecessary trauma
and it's really inappropriate
we're trying to make sure that everyone
is seen and heard and that's why we are
trying to completely shut out the public
the reason this is a problem now is
because some awful conservative school
board members are
inviting the public in to have a say
over the public schools but we want to
make sure everyone's seen and heard
which is why we've got to shut up the
public and keep them out so they can't
figure out what's going on don't you
understand that's progress when has
progress
ever been a bad thing in human history
like what you think that progress would
ever
lead to a system of eugenics actually
not to invoke a nazi comparison but i
guess that's the topic of the day
the early progressive era was the
pioneering era
of modern eugenics right
it was the progressives pushing eugenics
people like
margaret sanger people like george
bernard shaw people uh many
many prominent progressives that's bad
right can we ign the left still pursues
the same
system today but they at least don't
acknowledge it back in the early 20th
century
they did they they embraced it they said
of course we need to get rid of all
these undesirables in our population
i'm not you know i don't want to be i
don't want to be condemned by the
republicans in the house so i can't
i guess i can't make the comparison to
germany you know but uh
but it's funny because the school board
member totally sets it up you see the
total confidence in progress
the total confidence of progress is not
it's not about bringing everyone in and
making sure everyone is heard and
democracy and the people it's
quite the opposite of that because
progress is scientific
right progress we know the science of
history we know the science of politics
and so actually the more progress we
have
the more progress we want the less
democracy we can tolerate
because those people are just going to
get in the way of the science that we
the leftists have figured out that you
just got to trust us it'll all be fine
stop oh man that was close
ring the bell subscribe like so that you
will get notifications and
beyond that sure it's good to get the
notifications on youtube but you got to
head on over to apple podcasts
google play spotify myspace live journal
i don't know
all those podcast apps where you can get
the audio version there have been some
shenanigans recently with the big tech
companies
head on over there subscribe please
leave a five star review we'll see you
next time